qu'est ce qu'on attend c'est le drame du
ayong ce cargo baptisé l'exodus
vietnamien et qui derrière le drame de
2564 réfugiés cache la réalité d'un
vietnam que nous évoquerons tout à
l'heure à travers le reportage de
jacques à bouchard après leur reportage
nous engagerons une discussion entre des
personnalités qui manifestement n'ont
pas le même point de vue sur les raisons
de ce drame
il s'agit de monsieur rené andrieu de
l'humanité d'andré glucksmann du docteur
bernard kouchner de madame von haye qui
s'occupe tous deux du comité français
pour un bateau pour le vietnam
j'ai discuté avec son coadjuteur pendent
longuement assaillants
non je m'excuse non les ij dollar je
m'excuse monsieur x man qui m'empêchera
de parler ici ce soir kelly rowland
d'ailleurs à présenter je représente un
grand parti qui s'est battu pour défier
la maire fabienne larouche voulait
ramener ses dires les et vous taisez
vous je sers monsieur je sais quand vous
appelez je sais que vous voulez de se
taire je voudrais continuer les foules
être un provocateur et vous ne
représentez ici vous est un erreur si
vous êtes con place
ce que je voudrais que mon nez que je
m'en veux dire à part ce que je voyais
alors moi je dis aussi quelques mois
j'ai raté là je suis moi de répéter le
couperet des excuses de la part du débat
seul avoir dit que j'étais un policier
tout à l'heure aux égal il a dit vous
n'avez pas que je ne vais rien dire ce
moment là je vous demande de vous et que
vous disiez je vais regarder vous le
ferez garder les garder ce qu'on pense
que nous partions ensemble vraiment
dommage petits enfants des jaurès on
entendra enfin les réfugiés naturel
non merci monsieur riez vous restez je
ne reste pas en partir aux individus ah
ben voilà c'est la démocratie
allez y est aussi attendue que je vais
dernier je dénonce l'opération qu'abonné
en fait at elle dit parce que depuis
andrieu parler depuis à moi rires
fusaient les c'est ma vie c'est
parfaitement monde mais non pour chasser
sur le vietnam c'est bien moi je ne
reste pas avec voilà écouté le débat
n'aurait pas mérité face à leurs
landrieu